we did have one interview we had to take
down
which one oh uh tiana trump yeah we did
yeah so we had an interview with tiana
trump that went
viral as [ __ ] that was amazing that [ __ ]
was booming on twitter
there's like twitter clips that got like
6 million views on that that was an
amazing interview
we had this crazy ass interview with
tiana trump and vicki chase yo
i forgot i still got the clip in my
archive and
and right around that time we had like a
ratings meeting with our boss she was
like
yo y'all's ratings with females is in
the [ __ ] right now
so then we put out this [ __ ]
interview with these two porn stars
where they're talking crazy
yo i've still got the clue i think the
interview is on pornhub
i still got that one clip in my phone
right now and they were talking
crazy yo and then
well they took it down yeah yeah that
one that one was a little raunchy
but it was fire that [ __ ] was fire
yo that was one of my favorite that was
one of my favorite
that [ __ ] was fire yo me and head were
just like
because they were just talking amongst
each other look at each other like
yeah what the [ __ ] is going on over
yo that [ __ ] was wild yo look
let me play you this i got this [ __ ] in
my thing
in my phone right now all right i'ma
play the audio for your podcast but
bro when i tell you here's the clip
it's got it ready to go nah i had to
pull it up
look thing before i would just say it
was crazy just because it was so many
different like at the end
they when they needed to come it was so
many types of
different [ __ ] on my face like there was
like the
the like thick that comes and then there
was like the super watery combs and
they were and like all that was in my
mouth and [ __ ] and i had a swell like
the craziest one i would say i've done
is with a bella and they shoved a bunch
of gummy bears up her ass
and then [ __ ] her and they all melted
and she [ __ ] them in my mouth
wait what's your baby i want to eat them
oh yeah that's that's crazy
hey you know you know what in all
honesty we should have been fired for
this
[ __ ] if i'm being honest we put this on
the radio station west
i heart radio's instagram i remember dj
oh hit is like yo what the
[ __ ] are y'all doing over there yo hey
i ain't gonna lie that's one of the
moments where i was like yeah we
probably
out of here you know well it was nice
when it lasted
yo we gotta get we that was we shouldn't
did that we should at least bleep that
[ __ ] we shouldn't
did we put that on i heart we we should
not have done that
that was a rough uh that was crazy that
wasn't right i'm glad they kept us after
that
to be honest cheers